>> GREG: WELCOME BACK.
EVEN A TRIBUTE TO DR. KING
COULDN'T STOP JOE FROM DOING HIS
THING.
BIDEN IS STILL A DEVICESIVE ASS,
JABBERING ABOUT GUNS, RACE, AND
GAS.
NOT HIS OWN, BY THE WAY.
DURING MLK HE GAVE A SPEECH SO
OFF THE RAIL THEY HAD TO BALL
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO START
TALKING ABOUT SPENDING, GUESS
WHAT I REDUCED DID DEFICIT LAST
YEAR $350 BILLION.
AND THIS YEAR, FEDERAL DEFICIT
IS DOWN $1 TRILLION PLUS
DOLLARS.
THAT'S A FACT.
BUT THESE GUYS -- FISCALLY
DEMENTED, I THINK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THEY DON'T QUITE GET IT.
>> GREG: FISCALLY DEMENTED.
IF ANYBODY IS FAMILIAR WITH
DEMENTIA, ONE DAY, I JUST WANT
HIM TO WHISPER, THIS WILL BE OUR
LITTLE SECRET.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: BUT LET'S NOT FORGET
THE FACT THAT JOE JUST SIGNED AN
ABSURD SPENDING BILL LAST MONTH.
THE FIRST SPENDING BILL SIGNED
WITH A CRAYON.
LATER, HE ACCUSED CAR INSURANCE
COMPANIES OF CHARGING HIGHER
PREMIUMS BASED ON RACE.
>> IF YOU LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND HAVE THE SAME
EXACT CAR I HAVE IN ANOTHER
NEIGHBORHOOD, YOU PAY MORE.
NO BASIS AT ALL OTHER THAN YOUR
BLACK AND I'M WHITE.
>> GREG: STOP DRAGGING.
SORRY, ONLY TIME AN INSURANCE
COMPANY CARES IF THEY ARE WHITE
IS TO AVOID CASTING THEM IN
THEIR COMMERCIALS.
OF COURSE, JOE SHOULD PAY THE
HIGHER PREMIUM.
HIS CAR IS IS FILLED WITH
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
>> A LITTLE POLITICAL HUMOR
THERE.
HERE'S YOUR RED MEAT.
>> GREG: WHAT BETTER DAY TO
STOKE RACIAL DIVISION THAN ON
MLK DAY.
ONE MAN HAD A DREAM AND THE
OTHER MAN IS BARELY AWAKE.
WHAT A GOOD TIME TO TALK ABOUT
GETTING ASSAULT WEAPONS BANNED,
HUH?
>> I'M GOING TO GET ASSAULT
WEAPONS BANNED.
>> WHAT THE HELL YOU NEED AN
ASSAULT -- I'M SERIOUS, AND BAN
THE NUMBER OF BULLETS THAT GO
INTO A MAGAZINE.
THERE IS NO NEED FOR ANY OF
THAT.
I LOVE MY RIGHT WING FRIEND WHO
IS TALK ABOUT THE TREE OF
LIBERTY IS WATER OF THE BLOOD OF
PATRIOTS.
IF YOU NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
TAKING ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
YOU NEED SOME F-15'S.
YOU DON'T NEED AN ARR-15
I'M SERIOUS -- RAR15.
>> GREG: WAIT, YOU NEED AN F-15
TO TAKE ON THE GOVERNMENT BUT AN
UNARMED FACE PAINTED Q-ANON
SHARMON ALMOST TOPPLED
DEMOCRACY.
GET YOUR STORIES STRAIGHT.
I'M SURE YOU ALREADY SAW THIS.
UNLIKE JOE IT WILL NEVER AGE.
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO YOU DEAR -- ♪
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: I TOLD YOU.
IT'S A SHAME BECAUSE HE SPENT
ALL NIGHT MEMORIZING HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
SO JOE, ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD?
>> NO, NO, NO.
NOTHING.
>> LOOK, THESE TOUGH GUYS WITH
THEIR GUNS, WE DIDN'T THOSE
GROWING UP ON THE MAIN STREETS
OF WILMINGTON, DELAWARE, WITH
GUYS LIKE CORN POP.
WE HAD TO USE OUR BARE HANDS.
IN FACT, I RAN INTO SOME BAD
DUDES THE OTHER DAY.
I REMEMBER HOW THAT WENT.
I REMEMBER.
YEAH.
>> WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT, OLE
MAN?
>> STAY OUT OF MY GARAGE.
>> YOU BETTER GET YOUR ASS GONE
WHILE I STILL LET YOU.
>> THERE IS NOTHING IN THERE
EXCEPT MY CORVETTE.
AND SOME BOXES.
>> GET OUT OF HERE, MAN.
GET YOUR ASS AND BODY OUT OF
HOERNER BEFORE I KICK YOUR
CHRISTIA
WHITE ASS.
>> I'M POINTING AT ALL OF YOU.
HAVE A NICE DAY.
>> YOU, TOO.
>> YES.
>> GREG: NICELY DONE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> EMILY, MAYBE I HAVE AS LITTLE
MEMORY AS BIDEN DOES BUT I DON'T
REMEMBER PEOPLE ON MLK DAY DOING
STUFF LIKE THIS.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IS JUST RIPPING
[ BLEEP ] -- WASN'T HE SUPPOSED
TO BE THE NICE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE BUILD HIMSELF
OUT TO BE BUT THAT'S THE WHOLE
SHOCK OF IT ALL.
HE CAMPAIGNED ON BEING THE GREAT
UNIFIER BUT INSTEAD THE ENEMY
HAS BEEN COMING OUT OF HIS MOUTH
AND IT'S ALWAYS G.O.P.,
PATRIOTS, AVERAGE AMERICANS,
PARENTS, EVERY NORMAL PERSON IS
THE ENEMY IN OUR PRESIDENT'S
EYES.
WHAT ALSO KILLED ME, EVERY MLK
DAY, JUST BOTCHING EVERYTHING,
HE REALLY HAS, THE WAKE THAT HE
LEAVES IS LIKE, IT'S REALLY
DISASTROUS.
AND THAT'S THE THING AND THAT'S
WHAT I WORRY ABOUT.
I FEEL LIKE THERE ARE A LOT OF
JOKES ABOUT IT, NOT NECESSARILY
HERE BUT IN GENERAL, WE MOCK IT,
IT'S FUNNY TO LAUGH BUT IT'S
ALSO FRIGHTENING THAT IT'S OUR
COMMANDER IN CHIEF, THAT HE IS
AN UTTER LACK OF ABSOLUTE
COMPREHENSION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THE IMPORTANCE OF SECURITY.
ALL OF THAT.
ANYWAY, BUT MY POINT IS, DURING
THE SPEECH HE SAID FROM THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IF THE MOMENT
IT WAS PASSED LIMITED WHO COULD
BUY A GUN AND WHAT KIND OF
WEAPONS THEY COULD OWN AND THAT
TO ME IS AN ENTIRE ILLUSTRATION
OF HOW HE VIEWS OUR GOVERNMENT.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
CONSTITUTION IS IT LIMITS THE
GOVERNMENT NOT TO INFRINGE ON
OUR RIGHTS THAT WE WERE BORN
WITH AND THE RIGHTS THAT ARE
INALIENABLE.
FOR HIM TO COME IN AND SAY IT
LIMITS THE AMERICAN, IT LIMITS
YOU, BECAUSE YOU NEED AN F-15 TO
DESTROY THE GOVERNMENT BELIES
THE FACT THAT TO HIM THE
GREATEST GIFT WILL ALWAYS BE THE
BIGGEST GOVERNMENT POSSIBLE AND
THAT'S WHY HE'S THE MOST
DANGEROUS PERSON WE'VE EVER HAD.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: OH, NO, YOU DIDN'T.
OH, NO, YOU DIDN'T, JOE BIDEN.
>> THAT WAS --
>> SHE'S CURRENT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T LIKE JOE BIDEN.
BUT THE MOST DANGEROUS PRESIDENT
IN THE HISTORY --
>> WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
>> ON A BIKE.
>> BUT MAYBE SHE'S PROVING A
POINT THAT MAYBE PRESIDENTS
AREN'T THAT IMPORTANT.
>> HE MIGHT PROVE THAT POINT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
WOULD NEED AN F-15 TO FIGHT --
DIDN'T THE TALIBAN JUST DO THAT
PRETTY WELL?
I THINK WE LEFT A FEW F-15'S
WITH THEM, SOMETHING NICE.
>> YES.
THAT'S TRUE.
>> MAYBE THAT'S YOUR BEST SHOT
AT GETTING AN F-15.
>> GREG: THAT'S TRUE.
KAT?
>> I NEVER WILL BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTANDS HOW MANY PEOPLE
THINK THAT THE POLICE ARE A
RACIST MOB OF MURDERERS, BUT
THEN ALSO THINK THEY SHOULD BE
THE ONLY ONES WHO ARE ALLOWED TO
HAVE GUNS.
I DON'T GETS IT.
AND YES, WE CAN'T HAVE F-15'S,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE GOVERNMENT
CAN HAVE F-15'S BUT THE
GOVERNMENT ALSO HAS MANY REASONS
WHY IT MAY NOT WANT TO CARPET
BOMB ITS OWN PEOPLE.
LIKE ON ITS OWN SOIL.
AND, YOU KNOW, FOR HIM TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE NO CHANCE AGAINST
THE GOVERNMENT WITH AR-15'S,
ACTUALLY BASED ON THE MEANING OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT, IS AN
ARGUMENT FOR US TO HAVE MORE
POWERFUL WEAPONS.
>> GREG: IT'S TRUE.
>> NOT LESS POWERFUL.
>> GREG: YOU KNOW WHAT HE'S
DOING --
>> BUT THAT COMMENTS WAS
GOATING.
HE WAS ACTUALLY GOATING.
LOOKING AT JANUARY 6, IS THAT
IT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> BEAT THE GOVERNMENT WITH A
VIKING HAT.
>> I WANT TO SEE YOU TRY.
DON'T YOU MEAN YOU NEED A BETTER
GUN?
>> SAYING AN AR-15 THAT IT'S NOT
A MATCH, THAT IT PROVIDES NO
CHECK, KNOWING THAT OUR
POPULATION IS ARMED MAKES IT A
LOT MORE COSTLY OF A DECISION
FOR THE GOVERNMENT IF THEY WERE
TO SAY WE'VE GOT A CARPET BOMB.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> GREG: ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
CARPET BOMBS THE SAME PEOPLE
HE'S DEMONIZING.
THERE IS QUITE AN OVERLAP
BETWEEN THE MILITARY AND DONORS,
I'M AFRAID.
>> I THINK THE REASON HE WAS
BEATING UP ON EVERYBODY IS HE
THOUGHT IT WAS RODNEY KING DAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THERE YOU GO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU KNOW THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS TEAM WAS LIKE SO RELIEVED
HE DIDN'T SAY THAT YESTERDAY.
BECAUSE HE SAID --
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAVE A THEORY.
HEAR ME OUT.
JOE BIDEN WHEN HE GOES OFF THE
PROM E
PROMTER, BECAUSE HE HAS SOME
DEMENTIA, WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING
IS A LOT OF REDRAWING.
YOU KNOW WHEN GIRLS PICK LOTTERY
NUMBERS, THEY ARE BOUNCING
AROUND AND YOU'VE GOT 17.
NINE.
THAT'S WHY HE'S SAYING THINGS
LIKE ECONOMY.
DEMENTIA, BECAUSE THEY ARE JUST
FLYING AROUND IN HIS HEAD.
AND THEY ARE THE WORDS HE HEARS
THE MOST.
DON'T TALK TO JOE ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
HE HAS DEMENTIA.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
I'M NOT EVEN KIDDING.
THAT'S HOW THE HAPPY BIRTHDAY
VIDEO STARTED.
IF YOU WATCH IT AGAIN, IN HIS
HEAD, HAPPY BIRTHDAY POPPED UP
AND THEN HE STARTED SINGING IT
AND YOU COULD SEE HIS FACE AT
THE END GO, OH, I DON'T KNOW HER
NAME.
LISTEN TO THE END, HAPPY
BIRTHDAY -- HE DOESN'T KNOW.
HE GOT THE WRONG LOTTERY BALL.
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> TRUMP WOULD HAVE ENDED THAT,
YOU FIND, LOVELY WONDERF